I hope you like taking important life
advice from a robot Google is working on
a new AI program that will act as your
life coach helping you navigate the
biggest moments in life like who should
you marry or break up with the bot can
give users other advice ideas planning
instructions and tutoring tips AI isn't
just disrupting the life advice industry
it could bring back your favorite Dead
movie stars
stand up
[Music]
you want to kill your own Tyler
legendary actor James knee died in a
tragic car accident 68 years ago but he
will reportedly be appearing in a new
film thanks to AI so Jessica do we need
to sign like a do not resuscitate order
like do not put me in AI
That's how you feel about it yeah we
don't want to be a hologram I did think
remember when they did the Whitney
Houston hologram yes and that was only a
few years ago and to think how far we've
come now that like Tom Hanks gave an
interview he said oh yeah I'm going to
be storing the movies for the rest of
time like they have so much already on
there that they can just keep making
movies with me I don't love it
um but of the life advice thing that
only tutoring seems okay that makes
sense to me that you you need homework
help something like that those are
things with right and wrong answers but
the idea that you would go to a bot
about like should I propose and then you
put in all of the qualities that person
has or I mean it kind of seems smart
that we're doing this already though
with Google and the swiping on the
dating apps and Siri I mean they're just
kind of making it fancier to me well
it's kind of like you know the old
advice column and then the person would
answer the you know here's what I should
do but I love their example of you know
this tortured question about should I or
shouldn't I go to my friend's wedding
because I really can't afford to go to
the wedding and it reminded me of this
video that my son sent me of Larry David
and he was being interviewed and it was
like we hope this guy's like I don't
know what to do the wedding is too far
is it a destination wedding and I don't
want to go and he was like what do you
mean you just say no like I never never
go to a wedding that's farther than an
hour away from my house he's like just
say no so just turn on just just ask
Larry David about that he'll answer your
question so Pete your mother is a life
coach is she going to be out of a job
now the robots are taking off oh no the
the her clients love Penny egg stuff
okay then okay she's a life coach she'll
come in she'll tell you what your
strengths are your weaknesses what did
you do for that prove
online yeah no I don't no Mom I'm sorry
there's like a training program for I'll
be honest I love her and she does a
great job at it I don't really know what
it is I know she gave me a frame picture
of all my strengths that's in a closet
somewhere wow you know out of them is
definitely not hair one of them is not
hair the other one's not television I
don't know what they are so but I
remember one of my good friends in high
school got married and his wife was very
young like 23 and she was like I'm a
life coach how can you be a life coach
if you haven't lived life that's true so
I think same challenges with computers
how do you factor that in Craig do will
shrink robots have couches in their
offices
do robots dream
I don't know I don't know either but I
tell you robot will be far better
artificial intelligence is already going
to be better at this for what I think I
did hire a life coach once because I
felt sorry for him how old was he uh he
was like in his 30s but he was a good
kid I don't think he watches this show I
hope he doesn't because it was just like
he had no there's no way he was going to
help me I was helping him gave him like
300 bucks and said just you don't have
to give me your advice just go away you
know um AI is going to have access to
the universe of knowledge trillions and
trillions and trillions of bits of
knowledge basically it has access to the
universal brain right and what does your
brain do every day you're what you're
doing is you're constantly sifting
through knowledge to make predictions
about what you're going to do next
that's what thinking is all thinking is
is like what am I going to say now
hmm maybe I should say something and I'm
trying to think predict the best thing
that's what that's what thinking is so
what happens is AI it it has all of this
stuff and it just crushes it down so
that if you have one question it gives
you the best predicted answer it's
better than any human being the downside
is the downside is we may rely totally
on that to to make predictions for best
paths forward which would then reduce
our thinking we wouldn't think as much
anymore because we would need to because
right now I'm thinking about what I want
for food right I may not think about
that anymore
every time I sit here on a Friday night
that's exactly what Craig is thinking so
I think it's for dads to be like this is
the person my daughter should marry and
AI will say it AI would be the best
thing to do you could like a I will look
at everything and go do not marry that
person parental intuitive sense it
doesn't have emotions it doesn't have
wisdom
it's all knowledge is fine without
wisdom without Penny hegseth looking at
you and giving AI is wisdom it's
trillions information is not wisdom all
righty how dare you we are very wise
here hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else